[Music]
any gay priest sin
no i'm for those of you that don't know
the collective noun for gay priests
priests it's an easy one to remember
isn't it
no because gay priests were in the news
because if you're a gay priest you can
now marry another gay priest and they
weren't allowed to for ages because it
was going to be confusing
during the ceremony because would they
say do you take this man
or
does he take you
who's the mummy
seems a bit awkward i'd like to meet a
gay priest though because normally
priests do that sort of
nominee part tray filio fish thing
whatever that is
i imagine a gay priest to be a little
bit more
a little bit more razzmatazz jesus
christ you look amazing
[Applause]
good to be here i'm in a bit of a weird
place right now uh
bumped into the ex-girlfriend on the
street recently wasn't ready for that
one
she looked great she was the one that
got away
we dated for six years she dumped me out
of the blue
because she said i wasn't manly enough
for her and at the time i liked her so
much i was like i'll do anything you
want what do you want me to do work out
join the army hit you whatever you need
i'll do it
she was like look i just need a manlier
guy i was like tell me what you want and
i'll do it she's like all right fine i
want a guy who will pay for everything
support me financially always drive
always open door for me protect me i'm
like let me stop you right there
not a man good lord of course you want
to date that guy
that guy sounds amazing i would date
that guy
my friends be like hey mark are you gay
now i'm like hold on you haven't met
jeff this guy's incredible he already
beat up my high school bully paid off my
student loans we're getting lobster
tonight
gotti treats me well but the sex
is brutal
brutal sex i am in a lot of pain here
i'll tell you that
i've been going a lot of gay bars lately
because my friend works at one so i've
been hanging out there uh
and my guy friends are blown away by
this they're like dude you go to gay
bars
that is weird if some gay guy ever hit
on me
i don't know what i would do how about
you just
not have sex with them
yeah i never got that you know uh you're
mad at somebody because they might find
you attractive like i'm not attracted to
nine-year-old women but if one of them
pitched me on the cheek and was like oh
mark you're so cute i wouldn't be like
get the [ __ ]
off me [ __ ] i'll kill you
i'm not gonna lie to you guys i kind of
like going to gay bars you know gay guys
uh
they make me feel special like last i
went to a gay bar some guy there told me
i had pretty eyes
that's amazing no woman's ever told me
that you know
this guy appreciated me for my looks for
once in my life and i got to tell you
feel pretty good
because you know like if i want to get
with a girl i've got to use my
personality
and i've got to be honest ladies i'm
getting really sick of having to bring
it in every conversation
you know it's nice just be able to kick
back and coast on these beauties for a
minute
[Applause]
i have a girlfriend now uh myself which
is weird because i'm probably gay based
on the way i act and behave and
have walked and talked for 28 years
i think i was supposed to be gay i think
like in heaven they built like three
quarters of a gay person
and then they forgot to flip the final
switch and they just sent me out and it
was like you marked that one gay right
it was like oh no was i supposed to and
they're like oh man
well this will be a very interesting
person
so be a very silly person
i was definitely gay when i was a little
boy
a lot of little boys are gay you know
they're very flowy and they have hard
opinions on things
i don't mean that i was a sexually
active gay man when i was a little boy
that's not what i mean
when i was a little boy i was more like
like a 67 year old gay man that's kind
of over it sexually you know
i was just like an old queen i would
come out to the recess yard and be like
everyone get out of my way
i just want to sit here and feed my
birds
[Music]
the gym teacher would tell me to play
kickball and i'd be like you want me to
do
what
real quick i just happened pretty
recently i was in a restaurant near here
in the west village
and i was at the urinal and an old gay
man came in the bathroom with a walker
like this and he said this to me he went
i'm either having a drink or i have to
pee you're living the golden years kid
not me like he spoke in rhymes it was
crazy
it was such a weird interaction that i
wasn't sure if it actually happened
i came out of the bathroom and i asked
my girlfriend i was like did you see
like an old man
follow me in the bathroom and she was
like john that bathroom's been closed
for 40 years
whoa whoa
do you know what it's a good job i
wasn't born gay because i don't know
what i'd do
why not if you're gay you'll be loving
it won't you i wouldn't yeah i don't
think i'm suited to it
why just the lifestyle what do you mean
because the lifestyle the way they walk
about over there showing off
being quite okay you wake up gay
tomorrow what's the first thing you do
do you get a boyfriend or do you play
the
i field you play the field yeah are you
going to are you going to talk the same
yeah maybe in time i suppose things rub
off if i'm knocking about with john
inman's of the world
i'm probably going to start maybe a
little sort of uh
give me something to say uh oh hello i
haven't seen you for ages
right so it'd be a bit different maybe
the oh hello
right i've seen you for ages it'd be
little things like that and people would
suddenly go
you met carl recently sounds different
so you know you go home you go home you
go
your dad goes all right so how's it
going i've been doing any diy
recently oh hello dad i'm i've been
there for a bit
um i'll wait till another for carl how's
susan
uh i'm not i'm not with her anymore
this is pointless because it's not the
life i would choose
okay but you've woken up gay but i
wouldn't i wouldn't believe it then
i'd just go i feel a bit happier today
don't know why no but then you start
going oh
you go down you buy a gay magazine
you're flicking through you're looking
at more [ __ ] than you've ever seen
before in your life and you're loving it
you look down some has happened what'd
you do next
i just wouldn't look at that magazine
again no you're loving it you go oh i
can't believe i haven't seen this
magazine before
people i've seen knobs before have you
yeah where
you see knobs all the time where gyms
and that
and don't say you don't look because you
do when you're in a gym
because it's there don't look if you're
going like that that's that's more of a
worry if you're not happy looking a knob
in the face there's something wrong
you should be comfortable with it just
just there you go
your neighbors nice people the people
live around great people i every day i
meet somebody new you know
this city is great because of the
neighborly people you know
but i did meet one neighbor interesting
story you know
that uh this guy he just moved in you
know next door to me
so i'm always one to to meet the
neighbors
you like to chat with the neighbors yeah
because you know
so uh i uh i went over to the i knocked
on the door next door to where i live
and i say to the guy i said hey i'm your
new neighbor you know and i said uh good
to see you you know nice to
nice to run into you you know welcome to
the the neighborhood you know
and so the guy said i said what do you
do for a living there sir you know if
you don't mind me asking
you know what do you do for a living i'm
a i'm a uh nightclub comic i tell the
guy
so he says to me he says i'm a i worked
out at the university of
science there he says i'm a uh i'm a
um that's a good school by the way
i can't remember the exact place sure
but uh he says
i i'm a professor of logic huh so he
says the guy says logic now what the
hell is that i never heard tell of that
he says oh well he says it's a kind of a
pattern of
uh a syllogistic er
well he says it's hard to explain he
says why don't i give you an example so
i said fair enough why don't you do that
so the guy says
well he says let me ask you a question
he says do you own a dog house
so i go yes i do he says well then that
means you
probably have a dog i said yes
he says uh well that means you're likely
to have a family if you have a dog i
said yes i do
he said uh well then that means you got
kids you're married
i said yes yes i am he says well then
you're a heterosexual
man i said yes sir i am he says well you
see that's logic there i
i asked if simply from finding out you
had a dog house i made this series of
inferences
and uh i have found that you're a
heterosexual man simply from the fact
that you had a dog house
well i said good god isn't that
something
okay uh so i said well i won't waste any
more of your time there uh
neighbor and i said i'll see you see you
later see you around okay well uh
i went i said come on come by one day
and have a
chicken with me as i left
so i left so i go
i go to get a bus you know to the bus
stop
and i i walked down to the bus stop and
i still thinking about this
thing that happened to me you know and
i'm standing at the bus and
uh uh no bus coming at all you know
five or six of us standing around and
one guy lights up a cigarette there and
he goes
he goes as soon as you light up a
cigarette the bus comes and uh
he smokes the whole damn cigarette no
bus comes
right so uh i said to the guy well that
theory really worked huh
yeah and the guy goes well sometimes it
works
anyways the guy goes what's new with you
i go well
i had an interesting thing happen to me
today i said i met my neighbor
and he goes oh yeah i go he had a hell
of an interesting job i said he's a
professor of logic down at the
university of
science and uh
so the guy says is that so he says la uh
professor of logic he goes what the hell
is that logic
i said well it's a series of sicilia
something or other right right
i said i can't remember exactly but i
said i'll give you an example if you
want to hear an example
yeah so the guy goes out right fair
enough
so i said let me ask you this i said uh
uh do you let me ask you a question do
you own a dog
house and the guy goes uh no i don't own
a doghouse
so uh i says the guy says oh yeah you're
one of them gays
and here we work right
[Laughter]
what great stuff you can learn
university of science there
all right and then the guy and then get
this
look at this there's more this gay guy
yeah invites me to have a chicken at his
fridge